de ce jardin il ne reste presque rien au
coeur même de cramât torch des frappes
russes ont réveillé ses habitants en
pleine nuit
nous dormions quand à 2h15 un missile
est arrivé
les fenêtres se sont brisées puis nous
sommes partis dans la rue ils nous avons
vu un grand trou dans le jardin
peuvent s'estimer chanceux car plus au
nord à kharkiv d'autres frappes en
toucher des civils un mort plusieurs
blessés
les autorités accusent la russie d' acte
délibéré sur moi
il y un supermarché des bâtiments
résidentiels
il n'y a ni forces armées ni la défense
territoriale ni la police ici il n'y a
rien du tout
l'attaqué a été menée pour tuer des
civils
dans l'est de l'ukraine les combats
intenses continue sur la ligne de front
kharkiv cramatte horst mais aussi
donetsk essuie de nombreuses frappes la
russie piétine dans le donbass mais les
destructions se multiplient avec pour
victimes collatérales les habitants
restés sur place à ce lot viande plus
d'eau potable ni d'électricité dans les
maisons les ukrainiens viennent
s'approvisionner dans ses pompes public
encore épargnée
donc
qu'il n'y ait pas d'eau c'est un vrai
problème parce que vous ne pouvez rien
n'avait rien faire vous ne pouvez pas
faire bouillir la nourriture
fin juillet le président hélène ce qui a
appelé les habitants à évacuer la région
mais beaucoup des deux cent mille
personnes concernées vivent encore sur
place